vous proposez moi vient de découvrir un
second jardin qui se trouve en contrebas
de l'escalier
donc on va leur dire un mot on va
profiter de la vue et si vous avez des
questions au cours de cette visite mais
il profiter d'une vue dégagée respirer
l'air du printemps parcourir le fil de
l'histoire des plaisirs enfin retrouver
pour ce groupe de visiteurs
ils sont les premiers à fouler les
allées des parcs et jardins du château
de valençay depuis plus de six mois on
va lancer a été un haut lieu du
divertissement au début du xixème
on voulait me retenir le jour de
l'ouverture voilà tout simplement pour
pourvoir les beaux jardins leur ensemble
de léser pops et c'est très un précédent
tournoi les gallo romaine de la
renaissance assez moderne xviiie siècle
c'est très bon des visiteurs aux anges
les guides ne boude pas non plus leur
plaisir si une joie une joie sur tout
mais vraiment beaucoup d'impatience on
on veut y aller quoi on attend vraiment
on n'attendait que ça pour voir des gens
qui malgré tout pas finalement attendait
cette reprise aussi il attendait que ça
de pouvoir retrouver leur lieu de
culture pouvoir faire des visites ou ne
serait-ce que se promener dans les parcs
donc effectivement je pense que les gens
attendait ça près v2 publics les parcs
et jardins n'ont cessé d'être bichonner
coupe taille fleurissement tout le
nécessaire pour se refaire une beauté
une fois recrutés les équipes dédiées
aux visites la direction du château
s'est mis en tête un objectif rouvrir
dès que possible pour expliquer
l'histoire de l'architecturé
tout ça c'est des choses qui se font
mais aussi en interaction avec un public
à sanaa ça n'existe pas seule
donc l'autre l'altérité je crois que la
grande problématique de ce confinement
c'est la problématique de l'altérité et
l'autre chez nous c'est non seulement
l'équipe mais c'est aussi public pour
profiter pleinement du château il faudra
patienter jusqu'au 19 mai date de
réouverture des intérieurs au public